this is a story of boy meets girl and
the algorithm that brought them true
love
the boy baraka from washington dc is
gentle laid back and attentive
the girl kalea from seattle is assertive
creative and persistent
while their initial encounter was love
at first sight
this match was no accident
the union of baraka and kalea was
planned in exacting detail
baraka and kalea are a perfect match our
algorithm predicted it the guerrilla
species survival plan is responsible for
managing the demographic genetic and
overall population features of the
gorillas living in north american zoos
one could say we function like a
high-tech heartfelt dating site for
gorillas but without all the swiping
the algorithm we use was created in the
late 80s which is seven years before its
human counterpart we use data points on
genetics and relatedness and combine
that with what we know about gorilla
personality and individual needs we
combine all that information to make the
best decisions for pairings
like any modern couple baraka and kalea
matched on a dating site fell in love
and moved in together with kalea making
the cross-country trip to dc
after two years together baraka and
kalea knew it was time to start a family
[Music]
western lowland gorillas are a
critically endangered species
our goal is to try to identify the right
male gorillas and the right female
gorillas that will come together to
create baby gorillas so that our
population will carry on for a very long
time
these creatures are extraordinary
humans and gorillas share about 98 of
the same dna we are similar in so many
ways
can gorillas experience love the same
way humans do we're not sure but why not
give them the best shot
at 6 25 pm on april 15 2018
baraka and kalea's son moki was born the
algorithm worked
moki will one day also be a part of the
guerrilla species survival plan waiting
for his chance to find true love